foreign
is in Raleigh hi Sully how are you
good how are you better than I deserve
how can I help
I was going to ask you about um the Roth
IRA and the 401K I'm not a big believer
in it
um I just don't know I've been always
afraid of it because we haven't had like
a great depression in a long time or you
know the economy just goes down so I've
always been thinking you know if I
invest my money in it
um there's going to come a time where
the economy is just going to collapse
and I'm just going to lose all my money
so I I have put tried it a couple times
like right now I have like 1 600 but I
don't know if I should get back into it
okay
no you should not get back into it if
you believe it's going to collapse that
would be weird
right the only way you would get back
into it is if you got new information
that changed your mind about your
conclusion
I personally think your conclusion is
wrong
thus I invest because I think the
economy is going to go up over time it
does go up and down we were just talking
about that but overall
the economy has grown 11.2 percent the s
p has gone up 11.2 percent which is the
average of the stock market by the way
11.2 percent a year average for over 85
years
that includes the Great Depression by
the way
that's the average
do you think
um like I'm looking at it like I'm
currently just buying like I bought my
house oh you bought a house
there's no guarantee with that house why
were you comfortable with that house
um I'm actually renting it I've been
renting it for a year and a half now and
I'm making like double the more but you
bought it
you're renting it or buying it he rented
it out and he bought it as a landlord
you're a landlord yeah yeah yeah okay
but I mean you bought this house and it
doesn't have a guarantee it's going to
go up what made you comfortable that it
was a good investment
because I I saw the potential in it and
I saw that I can actually rent it so I'm
kind of my mortgage at 619 but I'm
actually renting it 1 300 and I'm making
good money even though I'm not taking
any profit I'm still trying to pay off
the loan so what happens when covet
happens again and the government says
you cannot evict anybody
who chooses not to pay for 18 to 24
months
it just happened
yeah yeah that was just the other day I
think it's gonna happen again like is
there a possibility
so here's what we're doing exactly hey
here's the thing Sully that's ex you
know the weird thing is is you've got
all this positive and optimistic view of
what real estate's going to do and
simultaneously you're convinced the
stock market's going to crash
and uh but real estate you do have a
correct view of it not necessarily about
your renter but you look back and you
say gosh uh you know for the last 30
years real estate's gone up
real estate's generally been a good
investment and if you look at the math
on how much it's gone up in your area
you bought a house in an area that was
stable and had a good potential to go up
based on things that were happening
around it you looked at the facts and
the history and based on that you chose
to buy a piece of real estate because
you felt good about its future because
its history was good is that correct
yeah or
or bought it after three months the
value of my house spoon of thirty
thousand some already but you missed the
point yeah yeah how old are you
I'm 22. okay well yeah yeah so here's
the thing Sully you need to study the
stock market it has a similar track
record of going up in value over a long
period of time to real estate both have
excellent histories of making people
money
and so you have a
Poor Man's view of the stock market and
a rich man's view of the real estate
market you also have what I'm going to
call a delusional View and I want you to
learn this at 22 man and I'm telling you
from a guy that screwed this up
you just said I've already made my this
much money on my investment in this
property because it has been evaluated
at a thirty thousand dollar increase
that's not real money until you sell
this house if you sell it tomorrow you
made thirty thousand dollars if you
didn't sell it you hadn't made anything
yet and so when it goes up or when it
goes down it's not real money and it's
not real loss until you cash out and
sell it my house has gone up
considerably because I'm in Nashville
and Nashville went bananas the last few
months that's not real money until I
choose to sell it and so I don't count
that money I don't consider myself a
super like it's not real money man so
like Dave said you're choosing what you
want to look at positively and
negatively you got to look at all the
facts across the picture man you can't
just pick and choose or you're going to
bounce from thing to thing to thing to
thing to thing and you're going to be
the guy with a whole basement full of
Beanie Babies and no money
which Sully if you look it up in history
they're about the time you were born
there was a bunch of people buying
beanie babies and thought they were an
actual investment now my grandkids play
with them and the dog chews on them and
that kind of stuff so uh hey you know I
Warren Buffett most famously said you
know someone came up to him during the
2008 when the stock market went way down
they said Mr Buffett you know you lost
10 million dollars today on your
portfolio he said I didn't lose anything
and sell it
it went down in value but I didn't sell
it it'll come back up and then you'll
say Mr Buffett I'm you made money now
it's just where it just went up and down
until I sell it I haven't locked in the
losses or the gains and so you got to
keep that in mind folks it's it's just
it's it's on paper until then and it
ain't green paper this is the Ramsay
show